have you been feeling sick cat i i've
had a like light headache and i've been
no I don't have like lost ov sands like
scent or taste or anything like that
you're probably a symptomatic if you're
if you are exposed everybody that I've
been in contact widget after Texas so
far as tested completely negative mmm
and had no symptoms whatsoever which is
a big relief for me and I will say that
i-i've been a little humbled and I
apologize because I was not careful
enough when I came back it's one thing
to take a risk on my own which I've
always taken responsibility for to say
I'm gonna go I'm gonna do prominent you
stand up and if I catch that I catch it
but I wasn't I wasn't thinking on many
levels which was dumb I had to go see my
parents on Friday it never dawned on me
to be even more careful
iiiiii exposed some friends without
thinking about it so all of that stuff
was my Mia culpa I was wrong and I
apologize I think I was little I was
inconsiderate and and I've I've been
humbled because this this is lingering
for me this is not this is not it's not
like I'm over it this is a I'm fine but
I can see people not being fine
obviously as we know if you're old or
you have existing morbidities it's very
dangerous so I've been I've been a
little humbled I will continue to stand
up as long as those states or allow me
to I do want to reiterate that Brennan
and I when we went to Texas we've been
to Houston we've been Arizona we had to
go ahead to go do stand up by the Board
of Health by the club and by the state
okay that's how we earn a living and and
because Brennan and I looked at the
stats well part of it would that's how
we looked at the stats and we looked at
the risk we chose to make that decision
I take full responsibility for it could
I have been more careful coming back yes
and I wasn't and I apologize
so that's right I'd say
uh yeah I mean if you would have told me
that I'd have to be away from my family
for two weeks because of this I would
have done any of the shows I don't know
if I'm gonna do more shows in July
either I don't know if it's worth it
so well yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna have to
push Addison but but Brennan you're um
you're now you now have the antibodies
yeah I'm aware I'm it's more of I would
be fine it's more I don't know yeah I
don't know well that's that's how I feel
it's like you know I'm gonna sit over
here because I don't I think my face
looks better yeah IIIi think I feel like
I I know what you're saying like I just
feel like there's a was too [ __ ]
bright that is the worry right that's
that's always the worry how the [ __ ] are
we gonna how do you keep other people
you know safe but but I do have to say
that I think that anybody who has
antibodies is probably maybe a smart way
to do it is you can go back in the
workforce yeah
agree agree mmm I mean I do it cuz I
like doing it I don't have to do it and
it's just like you know is it you know I
don't know I'm weighing the pros and the
cons and interesting yeah it's a little
humbling when you get sick yeah I've
been fortunate enough where it hasn't
been too bad at all you know thank God
but yeah if I could redo it I wouldn't I
wouldn't a wet you know it's just not
worth it to risk my family and stuff
like that I really didn't think about I
was really thinking about was like you
and me and doing the shows and everyone
think about it here and then I get home
it's like ah [ __ ] you I got two little
kids my girl my girl gets it the family
super [ __ ] because she takes care of
everyone you know so it's like and then
you know of course my my in-laws can't
come over cuz my my my father-in-law
who's a cop you know here's a lung issue
so it's like alright well he can't come
over and see his grandkids now this was
like just stupid man yeah I really yeah
I literally didn't think of any of this
because I'm an idiot
like I have to I'll be I'll be honest I
was going to see my parents on Friday
and I and I their 80 and I didn't even
think of that
so I I was very tone deaf to it so yeah
I've been told I'm sorry but as soon as
I can tour these three cities or he can
wait til August and tour when it's safe
because if it's not safe though the
promise it's not safe and that the
province is never going to be safe and
I'm not waiting I have to say this - I'm
not waiting until the vaccine comes out
I can't and I don't think any of us can
I think that this is the dilemma that
we're in as an economy and there's a
world
III I think if you're if you're a
journalist if you're a politician if you
are somebody who has a job no matter
what if you have reserves you can you
can talk about a shutdown lasting two
years I think the most most people can't
know that time yes oh yeah I don't think
I don't think
nothing says August or September is
safer than [ __ ] July so I wonder I
wonder if somebody I'm not hearing
alternatives well yeah herd immunity
hopefully you know enough people get it
there's a herd immunity yes they think
happened in New York because they had
such a spike there and now it's down so
they're thinking that's what happened
there so the good news is the death
rates down ninety two point something
percent correct we're not gonna make
this a Koba thing I just wanted to
apologize eat a little crow sorry to be
a [ __ ] idiot but that's not the first
time for me anyway how about how about I
told my dad you know I finally told him
and he I tell my dad I actually have
pretty mouth symptoms not a big of a
deal
and then pause for five seconds me goes
that's fair like people people want you
to have worse symptoms like what's wrong
with people a lot of people wish we were
way sicker and I don't blame them
because we've been talking a big [ __ ]
game like idiots we've been [ __ ] like
blah blah blah blah blah back overhead
now both of us I deserve it he wasn't
careful here's the thing by the way you
know how we got it I'm telling you how
we got it you can
whatever you want when we're coming off
stage first of all it didn't help that
the shared of you we share the mic it's
not that I'll tell you what it is
because we all came in there negative
what happened was we happen to have gone
to the one County that was the hot spot
in the United States we got an Amber
Alert on our phone Saturday when Amber
Alert I mean yeah that's that's that's
crazy because man we got there Thursday
despite what I read I think was Friday
that's cases it's spiked in Arizona in
Texas so I was like oh you know we're
already there so we were in the hot spot
in San Antonio and we were on stage with
350 people whatever who were laughing
our direction and so that's an aerosol
and then when we got offstage because
the way lol Club is we had to walk
through the entire crowd people are
standing up and they're there they're
you know I'm talking to you Ryan Brennan
and they're laughing in there too so
you're getting all of that spittle yeah
that's what happens they pray right yeah
I mean they did this so aside from being
in a hazmat suit that was gonna happen
maybe the larger issue is you know
should we have gone in the first place
but I again I say well the Board of Ed
and the state and the club okayed that
they okayed it in fact we might get our
we weren't even restricted we I think we
had we were allowed to be more than 75%
of capacity I know I mean so if I could
redo it I wouldn't have gone I'm me too
I've been humbled again I apologize I
understand we have to meet everybody has
to be more careful listening us talking
now you gotta if you've been exposed you
just gotta be more careful
I was tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]